so what if you are somebody in an
organization who tries to create that
culture on your team but it is not
necessarily well-received by the powers
that be this is the most common question
I get no no no no it's not an indictment
it's proof that this is the biggest
problem we have which is we the unwashed
masses feel that something needs to
change the problem is our organizations
are being led by people why would they
want to change the system the status quo
benefits them why would I want to break
the status quo it's been very profitable
for me personally right or they've been
raised in a in a their whole trajectory
has taught them finite mind mindedness
it's worked and so that's what they know
it's not necessarily that they're bad
people it's just what they know so we
have to have empathy as well we can't
hate them right the answer is you you
cannot change their minds we cannot
control the things we cannot control but
we can take responsibility for the
things we can control
ie ourselves so we can choose to live
our lives with an infinite mindset and
we can choose to create trusting teams
even if they're small just around us I
have a boss I have the one subordinate I
have a couple colleagues to the left on
the right I commit to come to work to
ensure that they feel that I'm here to
support them and help them rise to to be
there for them when they need it and
make them feel like they're part of
something bigger than themselves and
though I may not be feeling part of
something bigger than myself when I come
to work because the company doesn't
really have a just cause I have a Just
Cause and I want to contribute to
something bigger than myself in the
world and even though I may not do it
through the company I can do it through
my team you have to be the leader you
wish you had and if enough of us do that
then we get the world that we imagine
and eventually we get promoted that's
this is a long play we have we have an
infinite amount of time and all the
finite leaders will die they're gonna
not a bad thing this just happens
and so we're building our bench we
accept that this might take 20 years 15
years so let's build that bench you know
and we do it by a that because somebody
will say somebody took care of me when I
was young and it was it made my it made
me love my job and they will model their
leadership after you but you have to be
the first one who says I'm going to lead
this way and it's hard and it's
thankless and it's lonely and it feels
worth it
[Music]